they're perfectly fine with just being
Lemmings and Following the Leader that
is not Republican members here's a
generic intro to a clip we wanted to
show you you know I think a lot of
people look back look at this and they
say you know everyone needs to get over
their ego uh this doesn't happen in the
Democrat side they somehow you know
there's always squabbling and personal
feelings this one doesn't like that one
but this is you know coming out in the
wash and everybody is watching it um you
know as a leader could you put that kind
of to rest for your party you think
listen I think it can definitely help
you got to understand with the Democrats
they believe in top- down authoritarian
management so they're perfectly fine
with just being Lemmings and Following
the Leader that is not Republican
members we believe in individual
individuality individual thought and
being able to represent your districts
so if you're going to transform the
people's house which I believe is 100%
what needs to happen from a body focused
on what the speaker wants and nobody
else into a body that it's about what
the member once and they work cohesively
there's going to be some growing pains
in moving back to that structure this is
a part of it but I believe we're going
to land This Plane we're going to elect
the speaker and we're going to get back
to
work